today believe it or not marks
seventy-three years since the
bergen-belsen concentration camp was
liberated by British and Canadian
soldiers during the Second World War
around seventy thousand men women and
children including Anne Frank died there
well we're joined today by one of the
survivors Rene salt and it is so good to
have you here we're very honored to have
you here Rene because no you were just
saying to his it this is something he
you went through a large part of your
life just not wanting to talk about we
couldn't talk about it my husband the
few mentioned Bergen thousand the tears
were running down his face so then he
was he was one of the liberators yeah
wasn't he we got these let me hold these
talk because I think these two are great
pictures and let me stop it's down there
you go there you go that one this one
here is actually at Bergen Belsen itself
and you it for what people like you went
through we know it must also been it is
equally hard for for these soldiers and
your husband as well to to come to terms
with with what they saw that's why he
couldn't we couldn't talk about it and
my mother died there 12 days after we
were liberated on the 27th of April so
what how did you end up there I was sent
to bergen-belsen from Hamburg Hobart I
was working there during the war and we
were sent there at the end to alter the
end they sent everybody away for on
death marches and in coal wagon
openko wagons and they sent us to Bergen
Belsen from the camp I was in you well
you are able to talk about it now you
same it hadn't spoken about it for 50
years because you now go into two
schools to educate children and let them
know exactly what what happened and and
I suppose to make sure that nothing like
this ever happens again that's why we do
it because it's very difficult to talk
about it even now
and we look when we look at the scale of
what happened I think that is what
perhaps for people of our age that is
still very difficult to comprehend the
the absolute scale of what happened and
how many people died in these camps it
is beyond humanity isn't it unbelievable
if you can't imagine people who are not
there I can't imagine what a place it
was it was how on earth do you ever find
any any sense of peace all these 73
years old can you can you sort of come
to terms in a way with what we did come
to terms eventually you couldn't live
like this forever but it when you
remember and you remember it quite often
in every day I look at the pictures and
that everything comes back to me it's
very hard to live with it it's very very
hard I lost my mother there twelve days
after liberation so what can I say we
can see you know all these years on it
still so distressing for you but what
what what helps you through what what
motivates you when you get up each day
and how do you do you get through those
awful memories well we do really want to
speak to schools you want to speak to
people that they should know what
happened perhaps we can avoid another
Holocaust from happening at the moment
the situation isn't very good the
anti-semitism is very bad all over the
world and we hope by speaking about it
to talk to children and to a doubt as
well that we might avoid another
Holocaust from happening do you
understand as a young girl who went
through that now seventy-three years
later do you understand I wonder if you
understand how inspirational or how
important you are to the future
generations being able to hear your
story well that's why we talk about it
because it's very difficult to talk
about it that's why we do it all the
survivors
have you been well you must at some
point of it have been back have you I go
I used to go back four times a year to
pull back to Auschwitz into the other
camps so what's that like because you
might think that you'd never want to go
anywhere near them well at first I went
back with the BBC they made a
documentary and now when our documentary
and from everybody they picked on me and
my grandson
program was called grandchild of the
Holocaust and they made it so they
persuaded me to come with which I did
and since then I've been going back
sometimes four times a year with groups
you know to tell them what happened
there can I just ask because you've just
I've just seen that is that your actual
badge
nothing nothing when I left someone had
the piece of material just print it out
because this is I mean obviously we've
seen in documentaries and movies and
things Jewish people being forced to
wear these it's it's a very just even
this is a very disturbing thing to see
see the people were labeled in this way
we had to wear one in front one in the
back without that you wasn't allowed to
go out into the street otherwise you
should have been shot it's a terrifying
prospect look Renee we really appreciate
you talking to us on on this anniversary
and as you say I think they the
important thing here is that we make
sure this never happens again I hope it
will never happen to gain to no one
that's a crucial thing thank you very
much indeed